in this video you're going to learn how
to do polynomial long division we're
going to go through three examples I'll
go through a couple together and then
maybe the third one you can practice on
your own so I'm going to show you some
different tips and techniques to make
this a little bit easier so let's Dive
In the first example it says X cubed
plus 6X squared minus 8 is being divided
by X Plus 2. so the way that we set this
up since it's being divided by X plus 2
we're going to put the X plus 2 here in
front of our
division bar now you remember learning
how to divide just whole numbers before
when you were earlier on in math and so
you're familiar with this basic setup
but what you want to pay attention to is
if there's any missing terms see how it
jumps from x squared to the constant
term we're going to put a zero term in
there a placeholder okay so let's go
ahead and do that we've got X cubed plus
6X squared
plus 0x minus 8. now if there was two
missing terms we put two placeholders
two zeros the reason we do this it helps
everything to kind of line up a little
bit better it's a little bit easier for
most students so now here's what we do
we say how many times does this x this
first term here go into this first term
here so how many times does X go into X
cubed
or another way to do it and this is the
way that I like to do it I like to say
what times x equals X cubed that's going
to be x squared so I'm going to put an x
squared right here and this is optional
but see how I'm lining the X squares up
I just kind of like that keep everything
organized so now what we're going to do
is we're going to take x squared times x
that comes out to X cubed
also going to distribute x squared to
the 2 that's 2x squared
I'm going to draw a line
and we're going to subtract now what
some students like to do and I like to
do this as well so traction is the same
as adding the opposite so what you can
do is you can change these signs here to
the opposite and add straight down so if
we do that see how the X cubes cancel
one another out
6X squared plus negative 2x squared is
4x squared
just bring down the 0x and the negative
8. okay now we look at this first term
again and we say how many times does X
go into 4x squared
or you can say what's 4x squared divided
by X or you can do the way that I like
to do it which is the same what times x
equals 4x squared and in this case it's
going to be 4X now you know you have the
right answer because when you distribute
the 4X to both these terms the first
terms are going to match so 4X times 1X
is 4x squared see how they match so that
when we subtract that first term is
canceling out each time
4X times 2 is 8x remember we're
Distributing
and now we're going to subtract now we
can also use that technique that I
mentioned where you can change the signs
to the opposite and add oftentimes
that's a little bit easier for students
and then this comes out to negative 8X
minus 8. again we're trying to get this
first term so we say how many times does
X go into negative 8X or what's negative
8X divided by X or My Method what times
x equals negative 8X that's just going
to be negative 8. when I distribute the
negative 8 to both of these terms here
we get negative 8X minus 16
we can subtract or change assigns to the
opposite and add so let's go ahead and
do that so that cancels out here and you
can see we're getting positive 8. now
notice that this is a constant which is
like zeroth degree whereas this is
actually the first this is first degree
when this degree is lower than this
degree that's our remainder and what do
we do with the remainder we put the
remainder
over the divisor so
and this represents your quotient which
means that's that's your answer right
there now just to talk about the
remainder for a minute
say if you have sixes going into let's
say 20. okay it goes in there three
times three times six is eighteen now
notice 2 is less than six what do we do
with the two we say oh that's three and
two six which you can reduce the 2 6
down to one-third so it's always you put
that remainder over the divisor and that
goes right there so Final Answer let's
look at number two now we've got 4X to
the fourth plus two x cubed plus eight x
minus one notice we skip from X cubed to
x to the first so that's important we'll
have to put a placeholder there and
we're dividing by x squared minus five
notice here we're also missing a term
okay so we'll put a placeholder there so
the way I would set this up is whatever
we're dividing by that goes on the
outside so this is going to be x squared
plus 0x minus five
and then this is our
uh what's being divided so the 4X to the
fourth plus two x cubed plus 0 x squared
plus eight x minus 1. okay so how many
times does x squared go into 4X to the
fourth or what's 4X to the fourth
divided by x squared or my technique
what times x squared equals 4X to the
fourth that's going to be 4 x squared so
when I distribute I get this first term
which is 4X to the fourth
4x squared times 0x is just going to be
0x cubed 4x squared times negative 5 is
negative 20 x squared
and now we can subtract or change the
signs to the opposite and add so that's
the method I'm going to use so these
cancel out this comes out to 2x cubed
this comes out to 20x squared
and we'll just bring down the 8X and the
negative 1.
okay so now we look at this first term
again we say how many times is x squared
go into 2x cubed or what's 2x cubed
divided by x squared or my technique
what times x squared equals 2x cubed
that's going to be 2 x and if we
distribute we get 2x cubed plus 0 x
squared minus 10
X okay so now we're going to subtract or
we can change the signs to the opposite
and add so notice those first terms
cancel out we get 20x squared plus 18x
minus 1. again we're trying to get this
first term right the 20x squared so how
many times does x squared go into 20x
squared or
what's 20x squared divided by x squared
or what times x squared equals 20x
squared that's the way I like to do it
that's going to be 20. so if I
distribute the 20 to all these terms I
get 20x squared
plus
zero X
minus 100 right
okay now we're going to subtract or we
can change the signs to the opposite and
add notice those first terms cancel and
we're left with 18x plus 99. now notice
18x is X to the first this is x squared
when this degree is a lower degree than
this that's our remainder and we put our
remainder over our divisor now when I
write The Final Answer let's go ahead
and write what we have here we've got 4x
squared plus 2X Plus 20.
Plus
18x plus 99 over
x squared minus 5.
and that's your final answer let's take
a look at one more example see if you
can practice this one on your own okay
pause the video and try this one see
what you get and we'll go through it
together
now we can see that this is being
divided by x minus 4. so the x minus 4
goes in front here
and it's going into
3x cubed plus 6X squared plus 0x notice
there's a missing term minus 9. okay so
how many times does X go into 3x cubed
or what times x equals 3x cubed that's
going to be
3 x squared when I distribute the 3x
squared I get 3x cubed
minus 12x squared
and when we subtract
we can change the sign to the opposite
and add and notice those first terms are
canceling so we get 18 x squared
plus 0x minus 9 just bringing these guys
down
and now we're trying to get 18x squared
so what times x equals 18x squared
that's going to be 18x
and when we distribute we get 18x
squared
minus 72 x
okay and we're going to subtract or we
can change the signs to the opposite and
add notice those first terms cancel
and now we're trying to get 72x so
remember we can say how many times does
X go into 72 or what times x equals 72x
let's see I'll do it that way so that's
72 and if I distribute I get 72 x
minus what's 72 times 4 let's see
that's 288 so that's uh
288 and then we can subtract or change
the signs to the opposite and add notice
those first terms cancel and this gives
us
279. now notice this degree is a
constant it's zeroth degree this is
first degree
so this is going to be our remainder so
we'll say Plus
279 over x minus 4. now if this came out
to a negative 279 you could write minus
279 over x minus 4.
you want to be careful though say if
this was like 279 and there was like
another term here let's say there was
two terms
in that case I wouldn't use a minus sign
I would just say plus and then I'd have
the remainder over the divisor so in
general I usually just put plus whatever
the remainder is over the divisor but if
it's just one term like a constant like
that and if it's negative you could just
write minus
so that's our final answer now the next
step after polynomial long division is
learn how to do synthetic division I'll
put a video right there where I talk
about how to do synthetic division it's
a little bit of a shortcut a quicker way
of doing it that you can use in certain
situations so follow me over to that
video and let's dive into synthetic
division